hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be starting a new series a two-part
series on the Evans gambit which comes
from the gioco piano so we'll go ahead
and get into it starts with pawn to e4
pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop c4
Bishop c5 and this is the gioco piano
right now and if you've watched the
video you know that white would like to
bring his pawn to c3 and eventually
bring his pawn to d4 attacking the
center but in the Evans gambit we are
first going to play pawn to b4 in like
any other game but we're going to offer
up material in this case a pawn on b4 in
exchange for rapid and aggressive
development that you'll see later on
here now black has two options he can
accept her he can decline in this two
part series we're going to be going over
the accepted line since it happens way
more often than the con lines so we're
going to be going over the accepted line
which is Bishop takes on b4 and now pawn
to c3 and there's three lines that we're
going to go over the first is if the
bishop retreats to e7 if he comes back
to c5 and if he goes back to a5 these
are the three main responses you're
going to see from black it once you play
see three so we're going to take a look
at those the main thing you want to know
we're going to be going over concepts we
are going to be going over specific main
lines but just know that if you play the
evans game if there's a lot of different
variations so as long as you know the
concepts of these you'll be okay no
matter what your opponent throws at you
but the first line we are going to look
at is if the bishop moves back to e7
from here why it's going to continue up
the board with pawn to d4 now there's
two things black can do here if black
tries to capture on d4 and we recapture
as you can see we already have
compensation for our pawn we're down in
material yes one pawn but we have great
center control our pieces are developed
adorn controlling the center our other
pieces can get into the action very
quickly and controls the center as well
this is completely fine for white but
let's say black tries to hold on to the
center by playing a move like d6 or a
common move that people like to support
this pawn on e5 at the same time they
want to have Center control as you can
see here like has a little more Center
control than he did before if you
capture it on d4 from here instead we're
going to disregard this pawn on e5 and
we're going to bring our Queen to b3 the
Evans game that the Queen on b3 is a
very strong move because our Bishop is
now lying down this f7 square the f7
Square as you'll probably heard me talk
about is a very key weakness in any
opening especially against black
especially during the Evans gambit we're
on down this f7 pawn if you can get your
Queen to b3 a lot of times it's very
good depending on blacks structure right
here it's a very good place for the
Queen to be another thing you want to
see in the Queens gambit is to have your
Queen on a3 a lot of times you can keep
black from castling kingside right now
it wouldn't do any good but later on in
different lines you'll see the bishop on
a3 can a lot of time keep the black king
from castling which is really one way
what we want to do in the evans game
that you want to make sure that the king
is being harassed the entire game and he
can't have any safety
so from here you may see a couple things
if black would really like to move
something like Knight to a5 again we are
attacking this f7 pawn so he would
really like to have some counter play
one of the counter plays he could have
is Knight to a5 attacking our queen but
this actually won't work we can now come
with Bishop to f7 that when he brings
his King to f8 now we have to move our
Queen he's being attacked obviously
swing bring our queen to a4 and once he
captures our Bishop we recapture his
knight as you can see we're even in
material now but his King can't castle
is Kings at me open this is going to be
very good for white not going to be very
good for black so let's return to the
original position as we can see in this
particular line Knight to a5 is not very
good he would like to defend this f7
pawn but a move like Knight to h6
doesn't work because now we can bring
our Bishop capture and once you
recaptured now we can safely take on f7
he can't move a move like d7 because it
would be checkmate with our Queen here
on e6 his only move is f8 and now we can
bring our bishop back to h5 and you can
see the threats that we have the King is
wide open there's no protection
we're threatening mate and one Queen to
f7 what's going to have a very good game
if we ever needed to we can castle have
King safety all of our pieces are
working here together and the black king
is going to have a hard time not losing
this game
so if you see the black bishop move back
to e7 there's going to be two things
that's going to happen one you're either
going to have great sooner control and
compensation for the pawn you gave up or
two if he tries to hold on to it with a
move like pawns to d6 then instead
you're going to be able to just
continuously harass this f7 Square but
again like we said before he doesn't
have to move date to e7 one of the most
common moves that you will see after b4
and he captures and we play c3 its
bishop back to a5 and then here we're
going to continue up the board with pawn
to d4 and now let's say he captures on
d4 now we're going to bring our our King
Castle kingside
we can't take with our pond because our
King was pinned down from this bishop
here
now if black continues to try to take up
pawns we're now going to bring our
Bishop to b3 again a very important
Square for our bishop and now if you
look at it we're attacking this f7 pawn
at the same time we now have two
attackers attacking this c3 pawn our
night and our queen now let's say black
tries a move like Queen to f6 trying to
hold on to this pawn and at the same
time hold on to this pawn on f7 if he
doesn't defend this pawn we're going to
be able to not only develop a piece but
take back in material and we're going to
have a lot of active pieces with our
knight on b3 so he would like to try and
move like Queen to f6 defending this
pawn but from here we can bring our pawn
to e5
he can't recapture with his Queen
because we have our night here on f3 and
he can't capture with his knight because
then we can bring our rook to e1
pinning this night down to the king he
can't move his night and if he tries to
move like pawn to d6 defending this
night now we can bring our queen to a4
attacking the king and at the same time
attacking this bishop this is going to
be very good we're going to be up in
material it's going to be very good for
white not so good for black now the
Queen doesn't have to come to f6 a lot
of times you may see a move like Queen
to e7 again defending this pawn on f7
and just giving back this pawn on c3
from here white king continued
development and taking pawns back with
Knight to c3 and as you can see black is
under a lot of pressure and what he'd
really like to do is castle but get his
King to safety so what he was going to
do from here is move his knight to f6
logical move he brings it to h6 and we
capture this King's no longer safe and
he can't move it to e7 because it's
Queens their logical move for him is to
move his knight to f6 so next move he
can Castle kingside from here we're
going to threaten that we want to make
sure that he doesn't castle on the Queen
on the Kings side so we're going to
bring our Knight to d5 now let's say
we're attacking his Queen so he has to
move his queen if he moves his Queen and
captures on e4 then he's going to have a
really hard time dealing with a move
like Knight to g5 we're attacking his
queen
he can't bring his queen back to e six
or seven because of our Knights next
move we can come in capture on f7 then
we can move our knight discovered attack
there's a lot of different things that
flap excuse me the white can do here
that are very good for white and very
bad for black if he doesn't move his
Queen let's say instead he challenges
this Knight here let's say he takes it
with his Knight
we can recapture with our pawn attacking
this night this night doesn't really
have anywhere to go
if his night comes here we can now bring
our rook to e1 pinning the Queen down to
the king you would like to leave this
square open for his Bishop to I down on
the e1 square can't move his knight
there if he brings his knight to d4
we're just simply going to take it with
our Knight his other move let's say he
brings it to Knight to d8 becomes Knight
to d8 then we can bring our Bishop to a3
attacking the Queen and forcing him to
make a decision as you can see here we
have all our pieces developed and ready
to get into the action and if you look
at black he looks very cramped his
Knights on the back row his bishops not
doing anything
his rooks not do anything he's not
castled and all our pieces are eyeing
down on black and we can get our rooks
into the game this is going to be very
good for white this is why we give up
material in the beginning because now we
have a huge developmental advantage and
now we a lot of times can have an easy
one from here thanks for watching part 1
of the Evans gambit definitely make sure
you check out part 2 the Evans gambit if
you haven't already please subscribe if
you haven't checked out the website
www.hs website comm definitely check
that out
everyone thanks for watching I'll see
you guys next video